[Music]
at 13 Scarlett Clark lives sleeps and
breathes dancing mostly because of how
it makes her feel when I dance I hope
that people watch me because I'm dancing
not because they're staring my skin
Scarlet's has congenital melanocytic
nevus or CMN for short an incredibly
rare condition where children are born
with birthmarks which can cover up to
80% of their bodies young age
my first memories would have been of
people staring I have a large one
covering my back and like hips and just
coming around my belly and I have a semi
large one of my arm behind the confident
teenager is a determined mum when she
was first born I have to accept it first
before I could sort of bring her up the
way we have and we've just always been
very open about her skin and never hid
her away this is from World Champs 2018
and future prima ballerina to top model
Scarlett is one of 30 sitters to have
their picture taken by award-winning
British photographer Brock L Bank
they're part of an exhibition which
shows the beauty that comes with looking
different as you can see he's got CMN
covering one whole arm and it goes onto
this Jody Whitehouse runs a support
network for families living with see a
man can be very difficult because it's
so rare to do this exhibition is amazing
because what we want to show is that you
can love the skin that you're in before
she was diagnosed with CMN for the first
15 years of her life Jody underwent 30
operations being put through
excruciating pain all to try to lessen
something that's never really bothered
her it's confusing because I don't know
anything different than living with CMN
so for me it's just totally normal to
have a big birthmark on my skin as well
as what's visible on the skin surface
researchers into CMN have found that
moles can also grow on the brain and
spine and in a small number of cases
those marks whether inside or out can
develop into melanoma cancer which can
be aggressive difficult to treat and
most often fatal
we will know the result by today
afternoon this small team at Great
Ormond Street Hospital is getting closer
to working out what might help the
genetic mutation is something that we
also find in some cancers so it is
possible to try and use different drug
therapies to see if we can target it
that way or we can try and actually
correct the change the genetic change if
we can actually reverse that change
inside the cells that have it we might
actually be able to stop it
parts of scarlet skin might stand out
but she isn't brave she doesn't want the
sympathy if she wants this for other
people to get over it it's so bad I love
mine I would never think about getting
it removed in any way Casey Spencer Sky
News